tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo mondo
sono fa dj ed oggi siamo il nuovo
videogame call il frullatore 4.500
questa è una cosa che tu li metti i
giochi che poi la metti in testa e
parecchi problemi
ho comprato da mia zia piazza mercato al
7 euro e 50 perfetto ragazzuoli siamo su
blackwood che è un videogame divertente
lo giuro assegnamento alla ragazza siamo
su blacc good che sarebbe bosco nero
test mi click o cliccare su di cerbo
bello leggi questo sì però stai calmo è
benvenuto al maniero di blackwood il tuo
compito resistere tutta la notte e
catturare le prove di attività
paranormali e il mio compito questo per
certo arriveremo a prendere alle 7 del
mattino ma [ __ ] perché non lo fate
voi e buona fortuna ma fortuna un cazzo
buona fortuna
[ __ ] vaart o dico io troy art [ __ ] tua
madre [ __ ] giorno
lei è una strega e lei il fantasma che
devo cercare non mi fa paura sarà questa
qui era la strega di blair
basta non fai ridere con valve facciano
le tan frasi già che c'è left click più
draghi cosa vuol dire dovuti a devo
trascinare le porte a figo tipo in
amnesia fantasma un giorno e tutte le
grace stanza vedo fantastico che bello
scommetto che nella cronologia guardi
youporn cosa sta caricando sta caricando
qualche addio e non caricare cose sconce
che sto su youtube non verbo smettere
e a completare dal 1800 che stai
caricando così al web
io c'ho l'iphone questa l'iphone grosso
ragazzi l'iphone grosso è mio è mio non
toccatelo perché mio cazzo
ma c'è un tizio salve c'è un tizio cosa
cazzo
cos'è se una cosa
oddio ma è normale io io vedo un vade
retro gesù non c'è nessuno mi stai
prendendo per il culo e finto erano è
sparito è sparito proprio perfetto come
non desta non si accende alla luce
fantastico garabito questa non è radio
maria però non va bene è la madonna che
musica di merce de carolis scava scazzo
oil.b caduto l'iphone os x che mi sta
chiamando mia madre mamma mamma mamma no
no no mi sta chiamando mi ama e mia
madre e io sono io che le volte
diffondersi su e sentite io posso
rispondere al telefono che è caduto no
se n'è andata la tipa si bene è andata
presenti
sono fa dj ok patti chiari amicizia
lunga ahimè è finito con storari le
merda basta spegne che fastidio il
telefono non posso rispondere al
telefono da bene cos'è successo
cari che ha lanciato libera terra guarda
che questo è sapere il sapere non si
lancia per terra in cui entry entry
entry pure si sieda su questa cat reca
che si è rovesciata la cadrega salve non
è bravo minchia posso entrare io entro
perché hai aperto e se non entravo però
non mi saltare addosso che mi incazzo
penso che bella sostanza già mi piace si
può uscire è stato perché lo rimanere
fino alle 7 del mattino io sto posto
della minkia dei quadri e prenderei un
momento per apprezzarli ma non è proprio
il momento in questo istante perfetto mi
scusi lei che sta col pannolone nel
salone che fa anche rima aveva fatto
arrivate via
no non è piaciuta non è piaciuta rimano
che cioè che ce lo fa neanche ti è
piaciuta volta è una zia io mi
avvicinerei molto volentieri se non
fossi sporca almeno no vabbè ma richiama
perché dove fa ste cose almeno fatemeli
voi jumps kercher non capiti devo
andarci a caio [ __ ] e io vado di
qui su luca ha tratto la posso vedere in
faccia così bella ragazzi non ce la
posso fare però va bene a fan culo ma
qualcuna pesco plus 6 pensavo di
saltasse addosso invece no ho dovuto
prendere coraggio e stato difficile cioè
apprezzato il mio sforzo lasciate mi
piace cervo ascolti non pianga perché
tanto è scomparsa non mi sono anche
preso il jumps che dovresti essere
contento no sentirsi stata brava fino
adesso non rompere i trequarti di
minchia per cortesia c'è una scala
ascolta i passi e le risate non far
scomparire la luce esattamente dietro di
me eh vabbè rega
bello bello complimenti ti intendi di
arte chiamerò andrea diprè che che
sicuramente valuta questi quadri è un
pene ho trovato capitava porca [ __ ]
cosa è successo
calmo zio che avevi star calmo subito
sono tornato qui dove ero prima
esattamente dov'era prima fantastico ho
anche preso la roba di prima quindi non
ce l'ho non ce l'ho messa qua che cazzo
me ne faccio di scuse
no ragazzi calmi e spuntato un cervo dal
pavimento non si sa dove né perché per
no no no no no ragazzi non avete capito
niente
cosa sei innanzitutto che non si capisce
non arrivano si può però che ha quindi
quando ha quindi quando sento sta roba
devo devo spegnere la luce non muovermi
ok ho capito soffermo sono fermo è vero
mi sono mosso cosa lo hai nella vita mia
cosa devo fare
fermo sono fermo sono ferma sono i
moduli ho trovato anche l'argento sono
fermo sono fermo forti di lui ridotto
fermo allora questa radio radio cos'è un
altro oggetto tratti due ragazzi o tra
due cioè vanno sentito dai non l'ho
sentito famiglia iniziare da qua ti
prego vedi lista calma perché non ha un
destro che ti giro la faccia apri
deficiente cava accalai da son cagato in
mano lurido cane fresco e ti sei offeso
nel cassetto fendi
cane cane calmo cane bravo cane bravo
non far pagare
ho preso questo non far kakà adesso
maestà porta quale intenzione ha
intenzione di aprirsi cece perfetto via
via via via via via apri apri apri
perfetto manuele alla poule train no no
no frate no lo zio no perché vi riesce
così stronzo nella picchia ci faccio un
circuito di formula 1 ragazze quando
lega 800 metri di corridoio ma che cazzo
di si sta spegnendo la luce
bene fa piacere pedico sono rimaste
accese però adesso sono solo spente di
là fantastico torniamo indietro
sto scherzando non voglio tornare o no
no no no no non amo scacciavano
scherzavo scherzavo sito veloce al
capitano è vabbè si è chiusa oggi lo
sapevo cosa c'è cosa vuoi un cervo mi ha
appena seguito per un chilometro e
normale scommetto che nella carne nel
mcdonald's è proprio quel ciarmoli non
so perché mi aprite st porta o perfetto
tutto legherò in staccata mi piace mi fa
piacere
c'è un albero e mi sa che hai sbagliato
a piantare l'albero frate non ti volevo
dire è per ora c'è intenzione di forte
atene va bene così permesso
qualcuno ha voglia di spiegarmi perché
un cervo ha tentato di stuprare milano
salve
si apre questa portandosi anche la porta
non si apre la porta e che cosa ci devo
fare io non lo so blackfoot no come è
finito così ragazzi mi sto rifiutando
cosa sta cosa cosa ha appena giocato
spiegatemi michael moore vane e [ __ ]
dove il cazzo è finita dovevano salvarmi
alle 7 del mattino
no perché non avete completamente ho
messo quella parte caso me ne foste
accorti e ve lo sto dicendo da casa
ragazzine sotto piacere giocare a questi
giochi con il sono all'attore 3.500
prega solis far capire mi sei piaciuto
spero che siate anche voi amanti dei
cervi perché io dopo questo video penso
di si spera che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi
e como santos e video è piaciuto
documento è un bel mi piace anche a
speciali facebook e come nei video
trovate in description sera city 16
vediamo la propria vita ha ricordato i
tempi e cervi che sono cattive persone
da ragazze